[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's the lord's day pilot to Bombardier
you dare enter this [ __ ] house
[Music]
you
oh [ __ ] uncle Joey here [ __ ] Sunday
the 9th of [ __ ] April I'm back and
black
it took the whole day to get back from
Buffalo but I made a [ __ ] we got
to tremendous Rufus today we got the
colossal og then we got this skittles
and [ __ ] but the most important thing is
that we're here uncle Joey's back
I missed you [ __ ] I've been
doing my thing I was in Buffalo I was
[ __ ] on the set you know how we do it
dog always move in the [ __ ] head for
starters I'm gonna give a shout-out to
my Canadian [ __ ] [ __ ] then I
met up in Buffalo this weekend
especially the two dudes three dudes at
the hotel
the dude when I was checking out on the
way out Canada I loved him someday we're
gonna get this warrant fixed and we're
gonna be able to go up there and [ __ ]
rock the house beside that it's a
beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive
I got two containers a reefer the sun's
out the birds are chirping I'm going to
jujitsu and I'm home for three weeks I
don't have them do [ __ ] oh gods that
said let's fill up our first little ball
on him it's good to see you guys I
missed you you know I miss you
[ __ ] with all my heart I'm
gonna move and it was [ __ ] called I
couldn't do a periscope outside it was
snow and it was ready so just bear with
me this week I'll give you the attention
you're [ __ ] deserve you know why
because I love you [ __ ] but
enough is enough
let's spark up a number here and get
this party started
out of respect Palm Sunday Jesus Christ
grandpa is back beside that we got a
podcast at night five o'clock Pacific 8
o'clock Eastern we have a podcast
tomorrow night
next week 420 Oxnard 11 Eli are you
[ __ ] kidding me or what the week
after that I'm in Bakersfield at the
Templar the week after that Mormons wash
that [ __ ] uncle Joey's coming to Salt
Lake City wise guys foot
it never ends and I'm saying this but
listen what he will quit it's the Lord's
Day today is the most important day in
your [ __ ] world every Sunday beside
having [ __ ] dinner with your family
you know and all that type of [ __ ] you
gotta get this set the wheat up is that
name you're shooting pool you know I'm
saying you're hitting this ball but
you're thinking about that ball over
there for the move afterwards this is
what happens on a [ __ ] son that you
sit on you get the note booked out you
write Monday through Sunday and I hate
the blue and now you're gonna put the
week together I don't know but we're
doing the [ __ ] a little tape today we
don't have you drunk and keep knocking
we got [ __ ] to do and we do see we got
time for another bowl here maybe two
kaput
we got a mix in the skills right now oh
[ __ ] oh I left is he I'm saying
sometimes I get different array of weeds
i dry him out and I leave like two at
home over the weekend when I come back I
don't you have to go a little weed store
it's right here dry ready to go
I got a day I got a weed store tomorrow
or stop up for a week one more week of
Lent
that means no edibles again this [ __ ]
week is the last week I did it you
understand me unless I cracked on
[ __ ] Good Friday or something
[Music]
so as I was saying today is the day to
just switch things around
prepare your week do a couple push-ups
that type of [ __ ] and get the week set
up you have no problems my [ __ ]
Friday you'll know exactly what you did
you'll feel better by yourself and you
look at your notebook and go holy [ __ ] I
put a [ __ ] check mixed all those
things I guess I did eight out of kind
of last week I did two other times see
write that down makes it go [ __ ] by
have I told you guys - hi no I am I love
it when I smoke this new weed after I
come back I get a whole new [ __ ]
patois I'm saying I love Sundays I love
[ __ ] Sunday more understand me this
is when it all goes down the sun's not
out but he's trying and he'll be out by
[ __ ] twelve o'clock it don't matter
whether the Sun is that is not you still
have a swing they can give our [ __ ]
juju juice you follow me
so don't worry about the Sun don't worry
about how you feel don't worry about oh
my god hey who gives a [ __ ] oh all about
you today baby boy or a baby girl we
gotta watch that monkey you know
match.com ain't working out you guys are
happy I'm [ __ ] happy I'll see you
guys tonight at 5 o'clock Pacific eight
o'clock East and the Church of what's
happening now YouTube that's something I
don't [ __ ] know call a Swami I'd have
no idea
we'll do a pre church and get this party
started right you know I'm saying what
do you think should we smoke another
[ __ ] book let's movin out of all
I feel a little I have a couple things
to do I gotta set up my [ __ ] week I
listen to a little music my wife wants
people don't get why he went out of
mercy but I really want to get some
training in it so maybe I just train
here and go to the party likes about
compromises I go to jiu-jitsu tomorrow
and I said you know this is what it's
all about we all put our pants on one
leg at a time that's all [ __ ] what
they take ain't nobody better than you
y'all all these [ __ ] you sit
down
this guy listen we all put up pants on
the editor [ __ ] it's all about you today
ba-ba-boom look at this uncle joey's
miracle you gotta see this [ __ ] week
it's glowing in the dark
Kalama the [ __ ] dark understand
like Matt Bennett our brothers in the
dark
oh [ __ ] we're back gotta put [ __ ]
together young Sam ain't running the
[ __ ] cherry out there you gotta go
put [ __ ] together
ain't nobody gonna give you dick that's
a misconception you ain't gonna meet
some woman who's just gonna shower you
were [ __ ] kids that's a misconception
you're not gonna get discovered at a
[ __ ] bar that's right Duffy is not
quite a couple of jokes of the bar
Tarantino walking that's all the [ __ ]
fairy tale grab your balls salute the
flag you ain't taking no [ __ ] this week
all right
uncle Joey got your back I'm in town all
week so we've thrown a couple ease to
check it so if you have a psychotic
[ __ ] episodes or whatever is going on
let him go
there's no such thing put all the way
the medication focus and let's get this
party started
all right Vietnam is today not 20 years
ago
stay black 5 o'clock the Church of
what's happened now who loves you more
than me